The Joe Rogan experience,
but the beautiful thing about boxing is
that with everything wrong in the world,
and I hate to use this cliche,
this terminology,
but you know we'd live being unfair
because I don't like to use that
because.
Because sometimes people nowadays,
for me,
there's too many excuses out there.
There really are.
There's too many damn excuses.
You in this country,
you got a chance to do some where you
don't have in other places,
but having said that,
he can feel like life's not fair
sometimes.
Supposedly when you think about some of
the things we just talked about in a day
that's gone now,
it's not there no more,
but.
Well,
Dave Lewis and all those kind of people.
Life wasn't fair that really they really
had a right to use that say nowadays,
I don't think people have a white black,
purple.
They don't have a right to say that to
the extent that they did back then.
Not to the extent.
No,
no,
they don't.
They really lose all the things wrong or
they're messed up.
People still out there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But sometimes it's too easy to use that.
Yes.
It's just too easy.
I agree.
So.
But there was a time when life too often
was unfair.
Ruthlessly unfair.
Really unfair.
Were ruthlessly.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And when life was unfair,
boxing was around to make it fair.
And I'll tell you how
on one given night,
if you worked hard enough,
if you dream big enough,
if you were tough enough and you made
yourself tough enough,
you sacrificed enough,
it became polished and savvy enough and
and technically
equipped to do things that you had.
And you learn those things and you just
work yourself to the ball.
No matter where you came from,
no matter what part of the world,
no matter what,
who your parents were,
no matter what your poverty level may
have been made,
not a bit,
no matter what you had,
what you didn't have,
no matter what people had told you,
didn't tell you
all of that.
If you made yourself and took advantage
of that opportunity and get yourself
ready,
you already to behave like a champion.
You could get in that ring on one given
night and make the world fair and have
your hand lifted view called champion of
the world that makes box and special
and it's also,
I think in some ways there's a leveling
of the playing field that a lot of these
ideologies present to some people where
they,
they go,
no,
you're not a freak.
You're okay.
You know this.
There was some silly article on fat
acceptance the other day and it was
talking and then they got some proposed,
which is fine.
Um,
I accept people who drink except I've
accept all kinds of unhealthy choices,
but listen,
don't lie to me.
Just don't lie about the physical
reality of what you've done to your
body.
If you reach 400 pounds,
that's not,
that's not healthy.
You're saying it's healthy.
You're saying it's okay.
No,
you're just not dead yet.
If you lost 200 pounds,
you would feel wonderful.
That would be healthier.
Like if you smoke every day and you're
like,
look,
no,
cancer,
smoking is healthy.
No,
no,
you just,
your body is dealing with it.
Your body's processing it.
It won't be able to forever.
That is exactly what's going on.
If you're morbidly obese and for you to
pretend any differently and to just go
on about this fat acceptance movement
and you know the big beautiful this and
that and like,
no,
you're obese.
You've eaten too much food.
If you see a fat guy,
how come he doesn't get the same sort of
treatment?
Have you see a morbidly obese man and
his underwear?
No one's saying he's beautiful because
he's disgusting and he's fat and he's
lazy and he's.
He's addicted to food.
We all know it,
but if it's a woman were so inclined to
like accept just,
okay,
I'll let her go.
She's fine.
You're wonderful.
You're beautiful.
You're amazing.
Like can give her her space.
We treat them as if they're incapable of
recognizing the absolute reality of
their physical being.
I don't know how you feel about mumble
rap,
but mumble rap is one of the weirdest
things
to me.
It's.
I'm confused.
It's bizarre.
It's bizarre what is happening.
I just,
I feel like I feel like I don't want to
be that dude who doesn't get it right.
You know what I mean?
You don't get it.
I don't get it either I don't.
But when you start dealing with youth
culture and when I was the age of these
mumble rap kids,
they were older heads saying,
yeah,
you know,
the,
the generation before roster,
the cold crush brothers to the big daddy
kane.
So they probably thought what we were
doing was crazy.
So is that what's happening?
I don't know.
Maybe everyone's like,
what the fuck is that?
It's like I,
it's to the point with me where I'm
like,
Yo,
is that even a genre of rap?
Right?
Like I almost look at it.
I guess I don't,
I guess I don't have a problem with it
because I don't process it as anything
close to what I do.
It's almost like if you said,
Yo,
what are you think about Edm?
I'd be like,
oh,
I don't know.
August.
Is that right?
It's,
I don't even look at it like I can't
listen to that.
And then let him hear big daddy Kane and
think it's the same thing.
Kids listening to music.
Right.
If you were listening to something that
you enjoyed,
one of the things you loved was good
lyrics of course,
and when you can understand what they're
saying.
Yeah.
And it's also,
it's just so driven by phrase driven.
Yeah.
They just,
whatever the and over and over and over
again.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's just because these
kids are doing my alley or whatever and
they're just in the zone.
Is it drug culture?
Because that's happened before Tuesday,
you know,
one thing creates the other,
it's like chicken or the egg.
Are these kids doing molly and make
mumble rap or they don't mumble rap and
they eat molly and it's all,
it's,
you know,
the sixties,
you going back to the fifties and
beatniks and that scene and jazz and
heroin and w w what created it,
you know what I mean?
That miles and Coltrane make some of
those records because they were on
heroin or vice versa.
And it's happened historically.
Is this just a drug driven culture?
I don't know because I'm detached,
you know,
I'm detaching that and I,
and you know,
I'm,
I'm a kid who grew up,
you know,
listening to metal and stuff like that.
So I,
I don't,
I'm not at a shortage for Oleson to
slayer.
I'll just listen to slayer before I
listened to that.
If that's my only option,
then I'll listen to slayer.
You know what I mean?
I listened to black flag,
I listen to minor threat.
That's what I'll do,
you know?
So
whether I,
however I feel about it becomes
irrelevant when you realize that you
have so much good shit out there.
So I don't need.
It's like with film,
like I'm not worried about a bad movie.
I just watched the dope movie.
There's so many movies thrown them away.
Right.
And it's like,
Yo,
I was just listening to thin lizzy if I,
if I don't feel like adjusting to that,
you know what I mean?
And there's other things that we might
not get because we're not doing what we
used to do.
Maybe I was a bar of the clubs five
nights a week and you weren't married
with kids and we were hammered maybe a
challenge,
different time and place yet
because,
uh,
I am baffled by this carnivore diet.
Yes.
And baffled.
I'm baffled by how many people are
cleaning to it as a panacea.
I'm baffled by whether or not it's a
physiological effect or whether there's
a placebo effect going on.
I have a theory please.
Yeah.
So
my theory is that it mimics some of the
benefits of fasting,
um,
but allows people to persist for longer
because it's providing some nutrition.
You know,
most,
if you look in the scientific
literature,
fasting is the cure all for everything.
I mean,
like you can look at any condition and
fasting is the cure time,
water fasting.
So you can do it for two,
three,
four weeks from his,
tried that for a year.
That will be the cure for life in that
case.
The longest example is a year of
Waterford.
So most people are not at that last,
uh,
it was,
he was extremely obese of energy stores
this fat stores.
Right?
So that's one thing about that was that
he actually his skin trank to right,
which is really,
yeah.
Which doesn't usually happen with weight
loss.
So this is just a theory.
I have nothing to.
No,
I don't have any evidence,
but we meet as absorbed very high up in
the digestive tract.
And so when you only eat,
it's a low residue diet and there's
nothing leftover to irritate or inflame
the gut.
My theory is a lot of people who are
benefiting from this have really
disrupted gut microbiome.
Alessio Fasano has argued that leaky gut
is kind of a preconditioned for
autoimmunity and this,
the carnivore diet is,
it's essentially like a gut rast or a
fast.
And so I don't doubt that people are
benefiting from it.
The question is what is the long term
implication?
Yeah,
I mean I,
I'm not anti Quito,
I'm not anti Vegan.
I'm anti bullshit.
And one of the problems we have is
nutrition is replacing religion for a
lot of people.
So you find something that you identify
with and then people start to try to say
because they identify with that movement
or like for example,
vegans,
they identify with many of them,
uh,
protection of animals,
not my job to judge their ethics and
that sort of thing,
but then they kind of try to backtrack
to find the science to support them as
well and they,
they pick and choose.
And this is guilty of all groups,
not just vegans.
This is also a lot of key digital diet
cell.
It's a carnivore diet,
whatever have you.
If it has the word diet,
they're zealots out there who are going
after it.
And I will stick up for.
I've stuck up at a scientific conference
for the Ketogenic Diet.
Uh,
you were,
we were having a round table about
something different and somebody said,
well,
we know that the key to genic diet in
prayers,
exercise performance and endurance
athletes.
And I said,
I don't think that's necessarily true.
Uh,
you know,
the,
it's pretty ambivalent or ambiguous as
to whether or not it does.
It seems to be kind of individual.
Um,
but on the whole,
on the average,
it doesn't seem to impair exercise
performance,
so it's kind of what you like,
but when you have people who you know,
like,
like a Gary Taubes,
who says,
well,
calories don't matter,
it's all carbohydrates,
that sort of thing,
or the carbohydrate,
insulin model of obesity.
I mean,
the research is you're able to do a lot
of hand waving about insulin and you
know,
where you burn so much fat when you're
on a high fat diet,
which is true by the way you,
you burn a lot of fat,
but what they don't talk about is that
it's,
it's overall fat balance,
how much fat you store versus how much
fat you burn.
And when you're on a high fat diet,
you store a lot of fat,
you also burn a lot of fat.
The overall caloric balance is what
determines whether or not you will have
net storage or net deposition.
This same thing for high carb diet as
well.
You know,
this idea that with high insulin it just
completely shuts down all fat burning
everywhere.
That's just not true.
Now,
if you have high carbohydrate,
you will burn less fat,
but you're also storing less fat as
well.
And again,
the net caloric balance is going to be
what determines how much you store
because you don't really store
carbohydrates as fat.
For most people.
They did a study,
a overfeeding women where they overfed
them 50 percent above their caloric
maintenance and they found that of 282
grams of fat that they stored during the
day and adipose.
Only four grams came from carbohydrate.
Two hundred and 78 came from fat.